(gusty wind)
(gentle piano music)
(knocking)
- Sorry I'm late, I went
down a few different alleys
before I found this one.
Had to run from some dogs.
- There are a lot of alleys
in this neighborhood.
And feral animals.
- And nondescript white vans, actually.
- [Man] Down the way,
- [Woman] Drug deals, one sec.
- [Radio] We have a
rolling calender, here.
(indistinct radio chatter)
- [Radio] I don't have time for this!
- False alarm, they're just listing off
random dates and times.
Get in here.
(lively piano music)
Thank you for being so flexible.
There's all these drug dealers meeting,
and a lot of coke, and
you know what it's like.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, totally, I just,
I'm glad I'm here with you
for our one week anniversary.
- Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
(energetic music)
- Am I triggering a memory?
I have to stop making jokes.
- Oh, I can fix this.
We need something to make
this intimate and romantic,
and not like I completely
forgot our anniversary.
- No, no, no, this is actually
a really cozy surveillance van.
- Really?
- Yeah, and, and, watching
you do the stakeout
is actually kinda hot.
- What?
- Hot.
- Max, use your words.
- It's hot watching you work.
- We need to keep a low profile.
But you're right.
If I don't get these bad guys,
drugs are gonna flood the streets,
and then millions of people will die.
Wanna listen in?
- Can I?
- Uh huh.
- Yeah!
- Okay.
(indistinct radio chatter)
- [Radio] They're doing three, two,
- [Radio] My daughter does ballet lessons
- [Radio] one,
- [Radio] and oh my god!
- [Max] I get that, all I'm saying
is Ken Oshiro needs to work
on his communication skills.
- Well, Santella needs to
realize that Ken Oshiro
is running an entire crime syndicate.
- Yeah, but if Ken Oshiro
would just be open and honest
about how many kilos
he can actually move--
- I can't believe you're
on Santella's side.
- What, no, of course I'm not,
he cuts people's pinkies
off and eats them.
- And Ken Oshiro collects human teeth.
Who's to say who the better man is?
- Oh, I'll, I can go get food.
- You remembered our
anniversary, you've done enough.
I got us covered.
Write down everything they say.
I'll be back in one second.
- Wait, I.
(playful music)
- I love rice.
- Me too.
- I thought I was the only one
who ordered plain white rice.
- [Woman] Drug dealers, who knew?
- [Max] It's because they have ulcers.
- [Woman] I'm just really picky.
Oh my god!
- Is this the drug dealer's order?
(dramatic music)
(screaming)
- Where the fuck is my rice?
(Max whimpers)
- That's not loaded.
(gunshot)
- So it is.
- Arrest him now, please.
- But I dropped my gun in the alley
on the way to get the takeout food.
We're completely unprotected.
- Why?
- What do you know about Ken Oshiro?
- Nothing.
- Honestly, that Ken Oshiro is
not good enough for Santella.
- No, Santella is completely
happy with Ken Oshiro.
- He doesn't wanna deal drugs
with anybody but Ken Oshiro.
- Hey, we gotta cancel the drop tonight,
and torch a police van.
- He doesn't?
- No, he only wants to
deal drugs with you.
- This is the best anniversary ever.
- Same time, next week.
Did you just say is was your anniversary?
- Oh, one week.
- Well I hope you two are read
to spend eternity together.
- Oh, it's gonna hurt.
- [Woman] It's gonna hurt a lot.
- 'Cuz I want you crazy
kids to work it out.
(playful music)
(energetic music)